hello everyone my name is lucas
and i'm thrilled to be here to be
presenting you on this awesome event
uh well let's get started to it uh so we
don't lose
any more time okay so today we're going
to be talking about integrating
containers into javascript
in several ways i've been doing this uh
and how did i get to this and
how we can leverage this power okay
so basically uh these are my social
networks uh
this is my email my name is lucas santos
i am a developer advocate from sao paulo
brazil here
uh a microsoft uh and if you want to get
in touch with me
in any way just put my social network
dot l from lucas l cinders dot dev
okay so if you want to know anything
about me at all if you want to know
any other social networks just go to
info.alsantos.app
okay then let's get started right so
containers
they are a thing now right uh they are
containers containers are widely used
for
a lot of things they're used in several
areas with several technologies
kubernetes is here dockers docker's
docker is here
and there's like a lot of stuff that
actually uses containers
and uh it's something that's been really
active and really hot
in the technology area but containers
are new
they exist like since the 80s or
something like that they started in
linux and we are not actually telling
the whole story of containers here today
uh what i'm going to show you is just
how we can make this work with
javascript and why did i
choose to do that right it's easy to
control containers right it's
pretty easy docker is here to show you
to show you that uh
we can actually control the via like a
cli
or something and basically docker does
most of the work for us you don't need
to understand how the underlying
infrastructure actually works
because this is basically uh you know
uh not important for you to get your
work done
so uh controlling containers mostly have
been done by using clies or other
graphical user interfaces or something
like that but it's easy if you're human
right most of the clis and most of
everything we use now
they're made for human beings they're
made for people
right so docker cli is awesome it allows
you to do a lot of things
and there are other toolings that are
actually pretty good
in what they do to allow us to spin up
containers kubernetes is here to show
you that
we can have a good cli with control and
a lot of other things
but the point of all that is that uh we
we need to create things as if they
didn't were
uh they didn't were created for humans
right
so uh all this tooling has been created
to be used by humans in the command line
interfaces instead of programmatically
through an api or something like that
but what happens if you're not a human
if you're like a program an api or an
operator or something
like that uh you might face a hard time
by you know doing that for a lot of
reasons that i'm gonna show you
and now we are gonna just understand uh
what is uh what we're actually working
with right
so to present this to you uh we're going
to use a technology called container key
it's actually a tool
that was built by oci oci
is a the open container initiative it's
built up by
like a lot of companies including docker
and microsoft and a lot of other
companies
uh and the the basic
idea the goal of the oci is to create a
standard interface for all containers
and all images that we use today
so uh container d is a high level
runtime actually it's
more like a runtime manager because it
controls something called
called renzi uh inside a linux machine
so what we're gonna do today is that
we're going to spin up a linux machine
right so i'm going to use a linux
machine with container
installed and run c installed so we can
run our demos and our examples here so
basically this is why containers are
actually widely used in linux and not
so much in other os's right
uh it powers docker so docker actually
uses container d
uh underlying uh its implementation
infrastructure
uh it was part of docker in the
beginning and then was split up
into several other stuff uh and
container d
differently from docker or other
building
uh it was created to be manipulated
through an api or an
sdk client or whatever right despite
container d also has a cli interface
called ctr uh because it's actually
pretty easy to manipulate containers
using
the cli and basically container d
actually does that
for you if you have like a cli or
something you don't need docker
installed in your machine
uh and you don't need anything else
installed so it has a cli have
you know despite being created to be
used programmatically
uh but this is not important actually
having the cli
is one of the parts that will allow us
to control it
a bit better but that was one of the
attempts
but uh container d uh is actually widely
used
most of the container runtimes uses
container d in
underlying infrastructure or run c in
some way
but uh it's not so easy for
javascript developers so if you go
google
or whatever search engine or whatever
documentation you might find
you're gonna see that most of the
container things are done
uh using go uh
container d is actually built using gold
uh docker is built using go
run c is built using go and there's like
a lot of other things
that we can do but they are mostly
you know aimed to golang developers uh
this is one of the examples there are a
lot of other examples
but basically what we are seeing here
today is that we need to import
all the packages and you see that uh in
this uh
right hand most image here that uh we
have a container d
uh client that is actually well
integrated into go
and you can just import it and actually
create containers and delete containers
and pull images and so on
just uh using the golang cli which is
not actually present in
javascript but then i actually
came across a article that uh
made me think of it this is actually not
wrong right it's not actually wrong to
be written in go
uh it's programmatic and it's a great
code uh but it's not intuitive it's not
that intuitive for those who doesn't
know
golang or whatever other language so i
came across this awesome article by
marcos
how to get a browser to communicate with
container d through grpc
so i thought well if container d has a
grpc interface maybe
we can actually integrate things
uh into javascript so i thought well
what if i did this using node.js right i
know how to integrate
into grpc interfaces uh using node.js
i know how to do this uh using
the javascript command line and i know
how to use this
uh on javascript itself that we have
like a lot of
libs that allows us to create a
javascript
plain javascript job pc interface and
that are very actually
good to do this so i tried a false
attempt
okay so the first attempt i did was
sometimes
good mostly bad but it kind of worked
and it was ugly at all but the first
thing
uh this first attempt is just a proof of
concept uh
to show us that our two actually
actually there are two ways or even more
ways
that we can integrate container d into
node uh it's actually a simple way
to you know avoid being
uh so uh you know verbose and
trying actually not to know all the
concepts you don't need to know all the
concepts behind container d to make this
work
so the first attempt was to use chat
process
uh so basically what i did was that i
created a child process
and i spawned this child process to
actually create
instances of the ctr uh container
interface
uh and well this worked very very well
right so container d has this uh cli
called ctr which i already told you
uh and it's able to do like a lot of
stuff maybe like everything that
container d
can do is able to do you were able to do
via the ctr uh command line interface so
what i did was just
i put all these commands into a node.js
process
and try to build something out of it uh
i'm gonna show you the code but
let's talk about the pros and cons of
this first right so you might be
thinking well this is easy i can do this
at home of course you can do this at
home
uh and i encourage you to do so it's
actually very
very nice to see these things working
but uh the pros of this is that it's
super easy it's very easy to integrate
using a command line interface and using
ctr using chat process chat process is
actually amazing to use
and you have like a lot of tooling on
top of that that you can
indeed use uh and well this is one of
the the pros
the other thing is that it takes
advantage of all the implementation
that's already done
in the ctr in the face so you don't
actually need
to be uh so
into containers or you don't need to
know how container d
actually works so you can make
everything work inside javascript you
just need to know how to call a process
and you just need to know how to control
that
uh and well it's a faster implementation
so basically
uh you can do things very very fast i
did this and
i did this uh container decline in like
one hour or so
right uh and can be integrated into an
api basically if you can uh
manipulate this through the code you can
integrate this using the apis
uh so it's actually so simple that i did
this i did
this amazing container the api which is
basically
a uh you know vanilla javascript
running es modules in the browser and it
doesn't need anything else just some css
and some html
and it kind of works so as you can see i
can create i can list images so let's
jump to the code
and i can show you this actually working
uh
so this is our code and basically what
i'm going to show you is this
small server it's built using coa so as
you can see it's just
a few routes a delete route a boot route
and so on so we can create containers
this is our course
and we have a body parser and allowed
methods and so on
so this is a base kpi and this only
calls
the ctr okay so ctr is a container d
client that i
called container deep because of obvious
reasons and this
is actually everything that does the
work uh so it's already
running here i run both the api and the
application so this is the static
application that i'm running
using the uh go static
web server so this is all the same just
to serve the html
and basically what you can see here is
that i have my implementation of
container d basically using just shy
process
promises and uh this is actually it
uh so we have these actions that i
freeze we have the list name space
action
so i just exact a sync so i just run
an execution a sync execution of ctr
client this is
really really just the proof of concept
right so uh
we haven't if we have a standard error
then we just error out
uh if we have a uh another thing that is
an understanding error
uh we can pause this string
output so basically this is the idea so
i can parse the string output
i can run everything that i need
into this thing so uh basically this is
the
uh amazing container api as you can see
i'm a back-end developer i don't have a
lot
of experience and i can't do good front
ends
uh so i can't change the full name space
container is based on namespaces
so i can change the phone name space but
i won't do this i'm going to download i
have this
uh network manager here
open on devtools so i'm just going to
show you
how these things are working but i'm
going i'm going to pull this image
so i'm going to pull the go volt api
which is a simple image
it looks like it weighs more like five
megabytes or something like that
uh then i can create a container from
this image and i have uh
this website already open for um for api
this runs on 8080 so as you can see
nothing actually happens here because
the container is not running
but i can actually run a task to run
this container so
once once i create this task uh my
container is gonna run
here and as you can see i can actually
use my api
and i didn't need to integrate anything
into anywhere
so i just can i can just kill my task
delete my container delete my image
and everything is gonna be back to what
we had before
okay so this was my first attempt of
creating
something that uh was going to be
used as an integration for container d
right so uh this is not
it's pretty good but uh we have some
cons as you
may have seen on that uh the first thing
we have is that it's heavily dependent
on the environment you have so
uh whatever you were doing uh you just
need to you can just run this client if
you have it
installed in the same machine as your
container d
uh binary so uh if you have like
on you have a machine with container d
inside it
and uh you need to run this api in
somewhere else
uh basically you can do it because it
needs to be installed in the same
machine as the api
of course you can actually run
continuously around this api and then
run a reverse proxy or something on top
of it
to communicate uh externally or remotely
to this api
this is uh completely feasible right but
uh
there are other cons on this uh
basically we don't have any control over
the process
so if by any chance the ctr runs into a
problem or something
that we haven't anticipated and
being honest it's really really
difficult to anticipate any sort
of uh errors that happen in a command
line interface
because it's not meant to be giving you
all details of the error because
it's basically built to be used by
humans right not machines
so you can control all the process you
just control its inputs
and you receive all these outputs and
this is
everything that uh it's bad about it
because
you receive a output that's basically
uh a giant string and you need to parse
this string to
you know figure out whatever if you had
any errors or something
uh some of the clients like container
decline ctr
they have a quiet mode that doesn't
output headers or something
but uh it's you know poor i can't
actually get the container status or the
image status or
task status because uh these uh
these informations are actually hidden
behind a parsing or a table like
structure
something like that and basically what
you
have to do what we have to do is to
parse this giant string and use string
parsers and so on so we can
put this thing into data structures that
we can manipulate
okay so this is the first part but the
second part is that
uh this problem doesn't allow us to give
a proper error handling because
we just know that this is going to be an
error when we
haven't standard error output and the
standard error output is
meant to be used for humans so it's a
human uh
readable error and it's not a machine
like error it's basically what we do
is just receiving the error string the
error message and we can't
know for sure if that error can be
corrected or not instead of like we can
just parse it but
you know we can parse it by rejects uh
we can use uh
whatever thing that we can but this uh
is basically
running all the errors in one place and
trying to figure out how to parse
everyone
using regex and using uh you know every
sort of hacking that we
can do in strings so this is really
really bad this is one of the reasons
why
this api and this front end doesn't
actually return
a good error handling sometimes when uh
we're running to an error like the image
red exists or the image doesn't exist
uh it returns like a cars error or
something like that
and i can actually return this because
i'm marrying this out and
this doesn't return my error properly
right you need sudo to be run although
this is actually possible to
be removed you can uh configure it uh
you can configure its
uh container d to run this
uh in is as another user okay so there
is a config file in
i think it's slash cdc slash container d
uh config.tamal that uh allows you to
change the default user id and the file
group id that container is going to
create
its uh sockets and it's going to create
all this process so you can actually
change this
to allow you to run containers without
sudo but
it requires extra configuration right uh
and
actually this is the most important part
uh
we had the the error strings we had all
the output strings which is kind of
boring it's kind of
complicated to treat but it's doable but
uh the only thing that we need to
actually be uh a aware of
is that this is a huge security failure
because
we can input anything into that so
if we run into any attacks or if we run
any into any hackers or something we
need to sanitize all user inputs
for api because this otherwise can be
passed
on to our um container decline
and this can run some things that we
don't want to run inside our machine
right so you actually have to be very
careful on that
so the conclusion is we can integrate
containers into javascript
this is the first way this was the proof
of concept that i needed
to make sure that this was actually
possible
uh but i wanted to do this a real
integration like i wanted to integrate
this
without manipulating external stuff and
manipulating
things that are already there so i
wanted to actually create something
that was going to be native okay but not
so native because
it's just jrpc right so uh the second
attempt i did was to
read on to the container d j pc
interface so continuity
was meant to be extended you can extend
continuity
and it has a jpc interface that allows
you to do so
so uh if you have like this is these are
all the proto files
and you can see these are all the
concepts that container d actually has
uh containers content divs events images
uh introspection
leases and namespaces snapshots tasks
and
whatever thing else that you want to do
and this is like the image service
okay so we have a gather list to create
an update image and so on
the problem is you need to know how to
do it because
uh the interface needs you to control
every aspect of a container creation
pipeline
from downloading images to uh
downloading blobs
reading manifests creating containers
creating an oci spec for
both the image and the container uh
creating
uh all the bindings you need from the
file system to the container
creating all the flags needed and
everything else so basically
if you have uh anything that you run run
like uh you need
a lease for researchers need to create a
lease and you create a container and
mix that up together and in other words
you need to understand how container d
works under the hood
so in every aspect of the container
creation
in every aspect of how containers
actually work
uh for this you might need to you know
read the
oci specs for image uh the oc aspects
for distribution
or the oci specs for the artifacts or
containers and whatever
okay uh the run times back for instance
so uh this is the the example i want to
show you
uh if we if you need to create an image
like the list
uh rpc here doesn't actually get any uh
parameters it's just a filter a string
filter to filter the images
but they create one actually needs a
image type
so the image type is not just
a full image you can just download an
image and pass on that
image uh to the jpc interface
the image type is just a descriptor so
basically the descriptor is just a name
some set of labels a descriptor a oci
descriptor
a timestamp for creation and update and
basically the image is just a pointer to
a set of blobs
actually the blobs pointer to a set of
images but uh
the image interface itself i can't
create an image without even downloading
that
so i can create this image it's going to
be there but there's
nothing behind it there is no root file
system there is no file system at all
so in order to fully create the image we
need to download the content
so this is the service for content that
we need to download it and
these downloads are blobs as you can see
if i run like ctr content list
we're going to see that we have all the
layers from our image like
it's just three layers but those are the
blobs
that uh i downloaded when i pull the
image
and in other words you need to
understand all the flux of
how to download an image which is not
that difficult
but this is not very well documented the
documentation is a sparse it's actually
scattered everywhere right so it's
possible to do it
this is what i did i integrated with the
gipps interface so let's jump
into the code so you can actually see
this
working okay it's not that immense
example or something that's gonna
take your breath away but uh in other
words
uh it shows you that it's actually
possible to do so
so what i'm going to do here is just uh
i'm loading the proto files so the
profiles are here
they are completely descripted and they
are completely
uh downloaded into this thing so
basically this is the content protofile
and it's very well commented it's very
well documented here inside the profile
but not the whole pipeline process
basically what i'm doing i'm loading
these proto files using
the default jrpc module from node.js
so this is it's a bit laggy because i'm
using
x to uh execute visual studio code
outside of my
uh linux vm so this is running inside
the linux vm
uh so it's a bit laggy but i'm using
jpcgs in the product loader
to load an image definition uh and the
content definition
here down below as you can see so i'm
just loading the content.roto and i'm
loading the images proto file i'm
creating a client
so i'm creating this image client from
the container d services images v1
images
and i'm binding it to the unix
socket so this is the address that we're
going to bind to our jrpc server
okay container d actually allows you to
expose this as a tcp
and over http server and i can create
this without any uh
you know jpc requires you to have a
certificate because it uses http 2
under the hood so we can actually create
an empty certificate
using this uh and we can add this
metadata it's just a header
base basically so it's a header uh named
container the namespace and we are going
to use this namespace jsctr
right so js continuity and this is the
payload that i can
use to create an image so it's the name
of the image the target this is the
descriptor
the oci descriptor which is a basically
any size a digest and a media type
uh and the creation dates so i can
create this image using this payload and
that namespace
and i can list all the images using a
filter which
i'm just not going to use uh for the
creation
i'm just going to use the content
definition right
so in order to do this first i'm going
to run this for you
down below here npm start
uh and as you can see i can uh
download this image so i downloaded that
so this image is now
here and uh if i try to download it
again
i'm gonna have a error okay because the
image
is already there as you can see the
image already exists as you can see this
is a very good
error details it's a very good error
code so as you can see we have a code
you have details you have a lot of other
things
and uh if i execute this on my amazing
container api
here but changing the namespace to jsctr
we are going to see
that this is actually what we just
did but i cannot create a container from
this image because
uh it's just a pointer right so uh
this is what i did right now this is
what i had
time to create for this presentation
because these two
uh content definitions does not need
actually any
inputs so this is the output from the
container uh
as the content definition as you can see
this is just a blob file that is
put into json uh and basically this is
what
we have when we download images okay so
now
back to our presentation over here we're
running out of time
uh this is the pros oh every area of
this
every one of those two attempts have
pros and cons
okay so the first pro is actually we
have proper error handling as you could
see
we have a basically uh basically
uh interface for errors and a basic
interface for
handling these images and these messages
and everything else okay so we can
actually return a proper error to the
user
uh we have proper return codes so we can
actually return
proper errors to the user and allows you
to fully control
all the aspects of the pipeline so if
you have anything that you want to be
uh better or optimized you have caching
you can do whatever you want from this
pipeline like you can
download the manifest and put them into
cache and then
download this uh for further downloads
you can just look into the cache and
then download
all the blobs again or whatever you can
optimize it
if you can like find blobs into
different images that have
the same uh digest you can just use them
mutually or you can add
whatever future whatever features you
want okay
so it's basically the whole control the
best of the control you have
and does not need to be in the same
machine you can as i said
uh config container g to output the jpc
interface into
a tcp port but it needs you to have a
crt
certificate so you need to have a
certificate file both
for the you have to actually have to
have a certificate file in a private key
file
to uh be able to do that but once you
has
once you have this you can uh connect to
your jrpc api for
from whatever uh external machine you
have so it doesn't require sudo
because you are actually connecting
straight to continuity and it's
practically native okay so you're just
using a native module
non-native module you're using a native
protocol you can actually
extend this uh this is the standard way
to extend continuity okay
so the cons are that it requires a lot
of knowledge uh
i don't even know how to start
describing this because i didn't even
discovered how to actually execute this
in a
pipeline completely i'm doing this job
i'm going to tell you about this
by the end of this talk which is already
in
hand the documentation is a sparse
both for jrpc in javascript and
container d so you don't find these very
easily
you need to actually read the source
code for
go or not for google but for continuity
and ctr to actually learn how these
things work and how to build
the ocr spec it's way harder as you can
see
and might be a problem to connect
external servers since you need
these certificate files right and
you need and if everything to actually
connect to external servers so
what are the next steps we can do to
this uh actually
this opens up a very good opportunity to
integrate javascript into containers and
make like ci interfaces or whatever
actually you want to do using containers
so what i did is that i'm starting a
project
as you can see you can actually go into
my github account
and you can help me do this because it's
really really in the start of this
project
it's container djs it there isn't
anything uh that is actually
uh like it so i'm building this from
scratch
i'm going to use uh everything that i've
been
learning so far and everything that i
can find on documentations
to build a very uh native and very you
know
useful client for continuity so
javascript folks
can uh you know uh use this to build
their
own tooling and to build their own
better version of containers docker
and you know leverage all these
incredible tooling that we have
into other languages as well right so
let's add more knowledge and
actually create more documentation for
this so if you know how to do it
uh create more documentation post about
it blog about it
and actually share this knowledge so we
can create a better ecosystem both for
containers
and both for the javascript folks and
both for those who actually love
containers and love javascript
like me so uh basically this is what
uh this is what my goal is uh to create
more documentation into uh microsoft
docs
and whatever other platforms we have to
make more people able to create
containers and to understand containers
and to show them that containers are not
that
hard as it seems to be right so uh
these are the refs that uh i took so
basically all the
uh github files and all the repositories
that you're gonna see here all the code
that i showed you
is in these repositories so uh this is
the integration example
using just going and continuity uh with
a client
uh this is this is the js continuity
example that i showed you right here
uh and this is the ongoing work to the
container djs client right this is
mark's article about
jpc web interfaces and he has a lot of
good articles in his medium
i really suggest you to go there and
read it uh it's amazing
uh how he can integrate this into
several other languages like java
uh he can do this using grpc web it's
amazing
uh and well mark's actually one of the
people that
gave me this idea to try to integrate
this into javascript and make it work so
i can share these things with you
if you want these slides uh it's on
slides.also.dev
slash integrating containers into
javascript so i'm just going to leave
this here
and uh thank you so much
and it's a pleasure to be here if you
want to talk to me if you want to ping
me out on anything
info.alsantos.dev and well
i'm always available on twitter into
facebook or linkedin whatever
in github so if you want to help just
come on and ping me so
thanks a lot and i hope you have a great
day